à vanier marie le raku damien que les
compagnons de la capucine à l'europe par
le biais toulois compagnon chantôme et
les compagnons de la capucine viennent
de célébrer le vin et les côtes de tous
nous avons déjà évoqué les vendanges il
faut maintenant penser au 28 mai
ce vin a des qualités proches de celles
du champagne
d'ailleurs un producteur n'hésite pas le
champagne il prétend même qu'un
spécialiste aurait du mal à faire la
différence avec un véritable chant fait
mais le vin gris lui-même a conquis ses
lettres de noblesse il accompagne la
quiche lorraine et plus généralement les
ordonne ce vin a de l'esprit
il se boit frais réjouit le coeur et le
palais
monsieur vaillant vous êtes grand maître
de l'ordre de la capucine
je ne crois qu'il faut remonter un peu
dans le temps si vous le voulez en
particulier déjà charlemagne parler du
vin gris de la région de toul et
pourtant charlemagne charlemagne parler
du vin je ne sais pas si c'est du vin
gris aidé interdisait de le fouler aux
pieds
oui oui chers lobaye appris les édiles
s'est aperçu il avait les deux mains
dans la région ils en avaient après de
foucque à savonnières s'est aperçu que
les vignerons ont foulé les raisons aux
pieds elle a même pris en ai dit
interdit sans horizon le fouler aux
pieds et de se servir du fouloir depuis
charlemagne jusqu'à nos jours il ya eu
bien des aventures pour les aventures
oui la vie a connu bien des aventures
certainement la vie at elle bien nous
avons charlemagne et les gaulois que
qu'ils veulent et je la vis ils culture
a ri et que votre avis il y avait déjà
le vin gris à cette époque c'est à dire
que le varie dans le temps se faisait
sans pressoir ont tiré du vin dans la
cuve grant les raisins des foulées
écrasé ont tiré le premier qui coulait
et c'est ce qu'on appelle la grille et
eelv était dans des toiles où il meurt
c'est le but était dans des tableaux
très longue faire très très fort pour
résister à la pression et ils ferment et
fermenter sous pression quelles sont les
opérations pour fabriquer le vôtre 20
ans pour fabriquer ces faits avec le
plus court plus souvent avec les
réserves soient yabeh soit pilot
ce sont des uc prache noir à jus blanc
alors aussi tout la branche ont les
prêts sur vous en voyez vous pressoir
qui est là qui est sous pression même et
on le premier curieux qui coule et
presque blanc tu l or au fur et à mesure
de la pression il vient entre +1 teil et
si on met le dernier le dernier est déjà
beaucoup d'hussein contact avec le bas
avec la peau du raisin qui donne la
teinture au grain est-ce que les sous
vont il faut séparer le dernier le
dernier facile
leur arriverait à être trop tenté jusque
là plus d'une rivière à presque rose est
ce que les choses ont évolué depuis
votre jeunesse serré est ce que les
choses ont évolué depuis votre jeunesse
j'ai un jour malheureusement est ce que
les choses ont évolué depuis votre
jeunesse est ce qu'on travaille le vin
de la même manière maintenant à 20 quand
j'étais jeune
attendez les premiers vins gris gris
veulent faire moi c'est en 1892 les
champenois sont venus à cherré vent en
quantité pour melon banque est ce
l'amour là la champagne a probablement
eu une fille auxerre avant louer brooke
est devant et quand on est bien content
de venir chercher du vanuatu loup alors
toutes les communes du toulois
il faut un teddy pressoir est prise et
le vin sous pression ils vétéran des
fûts je m'en souviens encore des fusils
et surtout de pièces cercle et en bois
et sa portée par le train tous les jours
y apporter les bords plusieurs wagons
par la gare maintenant quand la pop et
plus tard lors et lorsque le vendeur non
plus priver les biberons champagne aura
ont demandé la délimitation s'ils sont
assez ingrat finalement les champenois
en vous avez besoin de vous ils vont
rouler autrement
qu'est ce que vous voulez il avait
besoin de temps à ce moment là ils sont
venus chercher quand tu encore du buzz
warda il court plus après tout le g
comprend